can talk about funding for the girls in
the band you said you started eight
years ago what was the first step you
took with trying to find backwards for
the film the first thing that I did was
go to a friend of mine named Michael
Green who had been the head of Neris
that's the group that gives out the
grammy awards and I have known Michael
for about 15 years and I called him up
and said I have a project that I think
you might be interested in so he said
well what is it so i told him briefly on
the phone he said well what have you got
on it I said well right now all I have
as a bunch of pictures and some stories
so I had a photo I have photographs I
made a book you know like you know a
folder that had a lot of of the
photographs of the women in it and I
wrote up the stories of each of them
that I had done after this year of
research and I went up to see Michael
and gave him the book and he said yeah
this looks interesting what do you want
and I said I want enough money to make a
demo reel and he said okay I'll give you
the money so we did we went out and we
shot our first interviews and we did a
seven minute demo reel and with that
demo reel we then went out to major
funders and started asking for money for
the project so that was our first steps
you